de fait dans la revue de presse
avec vous hélène frade bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline avant de parler des
frasques du premier ministre britannique
à la une de la presse internationale
bien sûr les trois mois ce mardi de
l'invasion russe en ukraine où la loi
martiale et la mobilisation générale ont
été prolongée de trois mois trois mois
d'horreur un pays transformé en champ de
ruines voilà voilà à quoi est réduite
l'ukraine depuis l'invasion russe le
soir constate ce matin que les armes et
2 poutine n'ont pas réussi à mener leur
offensive éclair mais qu'elles
continuent à pilonner chaque jour chaque
centimètre carré anéantissant des villes
entières dans une interview accordée au
quotidien belge garry kasparov légende
des échecs et opposant inflexible au
kremlin se veut malgré tout optimiste
pour la première fois la faiblesse du
régime apparaître au grand jour
l'histoire a montré que les dictatures
ne survivent pas aux défaites militaires
une victoire finale de l'ukraine qui
semble possible pourrait représenter un
coup mortel pour poutine je le cite si
le conflit en ukraine semble sans issue
certains pensent déjà à la
reconstruction
hier le président ukrainien a exhorté
les dirigeants de davos à aider à
financer la reconstruction de l'ukraine
après la guerre selon volodymyr zelensky
cité par dow financial times la
reconstruction de l'ukraine devrait
coûter plus de 500 milliards de dollars
et on reviendra sur ce discours à davos
à 9h15 avec l'hymne rifai qui notre
envoyé spécial au forum économique
mondial la russie de vladimir poutine
hélène où le pouvoir continue à parler
d'opération militaire spéciale en
ukraine d'après le quotidien
d'opposition russe novaïa gazeta qui est
interdit d'accès en russie des maires de
conscrits disparu le mois dernier dans
le naufrage du croiseur moskva
officiellement un mort et 27 disparus se
sont vu proposer de reconnaître que leur
fils était décédée à la suite de la
catastrophe le terme même d' opposition
militaires aux spéciales leur étant
refusé ces mères sont état de
déclarations a signé en échange de la
promesse de toucher 7 millions de
roubles soit environ 100000 euros à la
une également ce matin la déclaration
allez dans le journal de joe biden ces
dernières heures qui a assuré que les
états unis interviendrait militairement
si pékin s'emparer de taïwan par la
force cette déclaration pour le moins
martial provoque évidemment la fureur du
régime qui promet de réagir je cite ces
armements hors marc debai donne sur
taïwan des propos jugés dangereux dont
le but serait de vider de sa substance
le principe de chine unique selon
laquelle taiwan n'est pas un état mais
la 23e province de la république
populaire de chine après des années
d'ambiguïté stratégie qu'il était grand
temps de savoir si les états unis
défendraient lille contre une attaque de
pékin salue en revanche l' agence de
presse américaine bloomberg
fin de l'ambiguïté stratégique vraiment
le wall street journal qui indique que
la maison blanche a immédiatement
déclaré que dubaï 2 n'avait pas voulu
suggérer je cite un changement de
politique est beaucoup plus nuancé le
président est un maître de la confusion
verbale et personne ne peut être sûr de
la politique actuelle des etats-unis
vis-à-vis de taïwan le quotidien
regrette surtout que le nouveau
partenariat économique américain en asie
pacifique lancé hier vous l'avez évoqué
par joe biden pour contrer l'influencé
de la chine n'inclut pas précisément
taïwan une exclusion qui n'a aucun sens
à un moment où les états unis tentent de
prouver leur engagement de la région
selon le quotidien américain en france
est à présent débuts mouvementés si le
moins que l'on puisse dire pour le
nouveau gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes
confronter entre autres choses hélène à
la crise dans les hôpitaux du pays dans
le monde fait état d'une situation très
dégradée au point que 120 services ne
peuvent plus désormais assurer un
accueil continu des patients faute de
personnel la situation est
catastrophique
c'est une première dans arriver là
s'alarme un membre du syndicat samu
urgences de france qui a alerté la
nouvelle ministre de la santé brigitte
bourguignon sur le désastre sanitaire à
venir cet été si rien n'est fait
confronté à une myriade de dossiers
chauds le nouvel le nouveau gouvernement
doit en outre recourir à la
communication de crise après les
accusations de viol avisant le nouveau
ministre des solidarités damian ahmad
libération loi juge la position de
exécutif intenable la tâche du
gouvernement et elle les enjeux du
moment si important reconstruire
l'hôpital reconstruire l'école
reconstruire les sociétés que cette
nouvelle équipe ne peut se mettre en
marche avec des semelles de plomb vivre
ce que je vis est très difficile et
franchement tout cela est vraiment bas
c'est tellement injuste répond le
ministre dans les colonnes du figaro qui
rappelle que damian ahmad abad constate
conteste j'y arrive et avec la plus
grande force ces accusations et invoque
son handicap comme preuve de son
incapacité à imposer toute contrainte
puis pour finir plus léger quoique
hélène le dernier épisode du parti gates
mais alors que le rapport de la haute
fonctionnaire sur gré sur cette affaire
est attendu où vous l'avez dit dans les
jours qui viennent la presse britannique
publie en effet ce matin une nouvelle
photo pour le moins embarrassante pour
brent johnson un cliché pris lors d'une
fête au départ en plein deuxième
confinement le montrant loi levant son
verre avec un groupe de personnes
réunies autour d'une table qui croule
littéralement sous les bouteilles la
position de ben johnson semble elle
aussi de plus en plus intenable j'aurais
de la chance si je parviens à m'en
sortir réagi le premier ministre dans le
dessein de bên jennings l annonce de la
publication imminente donc du rapport
sur rai qui devrait permettre d'ailleurs
à une nouvelle enquête parlementaire
cette fois de débuter mi to moi aussi
répond l'une de ses compatriotes
confrontée elle l explosion du coût de
la vie
merci beaucoup et hélène c'était la
revue de presse à tout à l'heure dans
paris direct le cinéma comme arme